now that you have a product idea it is
time to move to the validation process
remember that a lot of ideas look great
on paper but fail in real life
validating your idea can help you
determine if your idea is as good as it
sounds as you validate your idea you may
find that your idea isn't as good as you
thought in that case you might need to
generate new ideas or combined old ones
with new ones just be careful that you
don't get stuck at this point in a
course we want you to put something in
front of users and understand the
process of going from an idea to a
product one way to validate your idea is
to do user research in the next videos
you will learn how to do user research
from Tom Bergeron our researcher in
Google New York